Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Avez-vous déjà fouillé parmi
les invendus d’un magasin ?
La première fois que j’ai plongé dans
un container, je suis tombé de très haut.
Mais je peux vous dire que
la chute fut bien amortie
car il y avait une grosse quantité
d’aliments pour me réceptionner.
Passé le choc de cette découverte,
j’ai enquêté personnellement
sur le terrain
et découvert qu’on jetait des quantités
astronomiques de fruits et de légumes,
certes un peu abîmés, mais toujours
consommables ou alors transformables.
30 kilos de pain par ci,
huit kilos de Saint-Nectaire par-là,
dix kilos de café en grains.
Plus étonnant encore,
des bières et même du vin.
Eh oui, il suffit
d’une seule bouteille cassée
pour que tout un pack finisse
à la poubelle.
Au bout d’un moment, ma colocation
de six personnes arrivait à se nourrir
pour 80% de nourriture
diversifiée et de qualité.
Tout ça dans le partage avec ceux qui
venaient récupérer aussi des denrées.
Face à ce constat, j'ai identifié
cinq problèmes majeurs.
Le premier, finalement,
c’est qu’on produit trop.
Le deuxième, c’est que les associations
ne peuvent pas tout récupérer.
C’est une logistique complexe
et c’est un travail de fourmi.
Le troisième, c'est qu'on doit escalader.
Je me retrouvais à devoir escalader
des enceintes fermées
pour accéder à des poubelles sécurisées.
C'est quand même dingue.
Le quatrième point, c'est qu'on jette de
la nourriture qui est encore consommable
alors que juste à côté,
il y a des gens qui ont faim.
Et le cinquième point et qui me choquait
aussi d’un point de vue énergétique,
c’est qu’on gâche du travail,
des ressources et de l’énergie
pour envoyer de la nourriture encore
consommable dans un camion poubelle,
qui va dans un incinérateur
qui, lui, utilise du gaz
pour brûler des aliments qui contiennent
une grosse partie d’eau.
Si vous me permettez la comparaison,
on en revient à acheter du gaz
pour brûler de l'eau.
J’ignore si vous avez déjà essayé
de brûler une carotte avec un briquet,
mais je vous souhaite bon courage.
Je connais des artisans et des commerçants
qui ont une super belle éthique,
qui redistribuent gratuitement
le fruit de leur travail
à ceux qui en ont besoin,
et qui compostent leur biodéchets.
Par contre, d’autres enseignes
ne jouent pas forcément le jeu.
Elles interdisent à leurs employés
de récupérer les invendus
ou de les redonner.
Mais il ne faut pas forcément leur jeter
la pierre car nous, consommateurs,
nous jetons chaque année 30 kilos
de nourriture par personne,
dont, tenez-vous bien, sept kilos
sont intacts et encore emballés.
Donc, on a encore du chemin à faire.
J’ai une bonne nouvelle :
plein d’initiatives fleurissent.
Il y a des conserveries,
il y a des cuisines solidaires,
il y a des applications
et des magasins anti-gaspillage.
À Clermont-Ferrand,
il y a deux frigos solidaires,
des lieux qui sont ouverts
à toutes et à tous,
où on peut déposer et prendre
de la nourriture de manière anonyme.
Ils sont dans la rue comme ça.
Pour ma part,
j’ai décidé de travailler en collaboration
avec les artisans boulangers et pâtissiers
chez qui je collecte quotidiennement
les fruits invendus de leur travail
pour vous donner des bons produits
anti-gaspi et à prix réduit.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)